The European Parliament office in Malta
has condemned the Broadcasting Authorities Directive
to limit coverage of European Parliament President
Roberta Metzola, labeling it unprecedented
and potentially stifling journalistic freedom.
The directive singles out coverage of metzola,
leading to concerns over political interference
and biased media representation.
Critics argue that the directive,
which could lead to sanctions against media outlets,
undermines the European Parliament's role
and violates journalistic principles.
Metzola's significant lead in polls
adds weight to allegations
that the directive aims to sway public opinion
in favour of the ruling Labour Party,
raising questions about electoral integrity.
The European Parliament office
demands the immediate suspension of the directive,
emphasizing the importance of upholding democratic norms
and ensuring equal access to information for Maltese citizens.